car
me
[music]
Nice to meet you. My name is Kyosuke Kindaichi. I'm a university lecturer lodging outside Morikawa-cho, my home country
.  But I love him and his talent.
Mr. Nomura takes care of his junior high school classmates and is very reliable. He
is like a big brother to everyone.
Mr.
Hagiwara is shy, shy, and has a lot of love. Mr.
Hirai rents a room in the same boarding house
.  is a fire that loves traveling and drinking.It
always appears randomly and disappears before you know it.But
you were introduced by Natsume-sensei
.
Ishikawa-kun said that he would start appraisal shadows because of the incident that
happened We who aspire to be literary people are very troubled to get involved
.